july is national carpet cleaning month
and it's the perfect reminder to get
that carpet cleaned but not all carpet
cleaners are equal i am joined by ben
mckee general manager of zerorez las
vegas the sponsors of this segment to
tell us more
not all carpet cleaners are equal you
guys are far superior and it's because
of the water tell us about your zero
water that's right so we clean without
any soaps or harsh chemicals and what
that means mercedes is as a homeowner
you're not gonna have crunchy carpets
you're not going to have weird chemical
deodorizers that are toxic put in your
floors you're going to have fresh clean
carpets like it came from the factory i
love when you guys come to our house
because not only do you have the fresh
clean carpets but i don't have to wait
three days for the carpet to dry why is
that you know our technology we have the
best equipment in the realm of carpet
cleaning our our vacuum cleaner is
basically a 300 horsepower vacuum it's
hooked up to the actual engine for the
vehicle and which is really rare in the
carpet cleaning industry coupled with
you know proper cleaning technique
proper training with our team we're able
to get these amazing results that you
see
and the results speak for themselves
actually doug's going to show us here in
a second but i want to talk about that
amazing team that you talked about you
guys have won best of las vegas i see
the difference when your team comes into
my home and how respectful they are tell
us a little bit about why you guys are
the best of las vegas well you know like
it's me doug and kevin we're all
brothers here running zero res and we
have families we we know what it's like
to invite a service person into our home
and so we just train our team on you
know the proper way to do it have
etiquette have empathy and you know
we're really there to serve and make you
a raving fan of zero res in our process
well we are and let's let's see xerorez
again in action here doug you're the pro
at this the master
first of all i don't know how you guys
managed to make let's hold on one second
while we get a shot of this carpet there
we go okay
you made the carpet so dirty i don't
know how you do that but then with one
swipe
boom look that's one swipe once what and
like you said it's an amazing time of
year to get your carpets cleaned you
know it's hot outside and we're getting
amazing dry times you brought that up
right now you can get your carpets dry
in as little as like four to five hours
after we're done cleaning which is
amazing you can get your carpets clean
in the morning have a party in the
afternoon you're good to go it really is
the truth i love that about you guys and
what i also love is that you always
offer our viewers great specials you
guys have a great special going on right
now we do i've
it's crazy that we're doing this special
but you can get two rooms of carpet
clean for only 89 right now it's it's
amazing take advantage of the deal
that's probably the best deal i've ever
heard that you guys have offered that's
incredible and this goes for just your
average wear and tear your guests that
have come in your pets that have
destroyed your carpet absolutely we have
an arsenal of products that safely and
effectively address not only the odor
issues but also the stains that are left
behind by our fur babies and don't
forget if you're a business you need to
clean up your your your business you
guys specialize in that too we do and
you got to understand your customers
even your employees
first impressions count yep i know
people are trying to hire right now if
you've got a dirty office that you're
bringing interviewees into
get it cleaned up call zerorez we can
help you with every aspect of your
business yes thank you zerorez for
sponsoring this segment you guys are the
best don't forget take advantage of
their national carpet cleaning special
like he said two rooms of carpet cleaned
for only 89 plus you can save 20 percent
on all pet treatments call 702-840-3333
or go online to xerorezlegus.com
for more minimums apply